back-to-back and this is again light
like mr. Sulu's under with a black I
think I also have wide against them more
or less always and let's see what he
does against my pad line here and in the
Scotch I know that Queen g4 can be
answered more dynamically with not have
six but I don't know that line that well
so I'm not not ready for that I just
have to admit not sure what 95 okay
where I can just take it's not a big
deal my div six might not be five i
would say f king d8 okay so
yeah that Knight f6 against could you
for its more dynamic but I never really
saw any problem with this line I think
black is completely okay here as well
at least I don't think why there's
anything anything special the icons for
that hmm and I have keen the aid taking
us is probably question of it but should
be 30 maybe I could have done that I can
take tea too wow I did not take okay
maybe I could have done that okay what's
this 95 it's not the most natural rhythm
and the c12 may be in place for direct
attack yeah with some be five stuff and
so on maybe he does okay Bishop g4 at f3
and I'm grabbing so he has to move the
rook I think night air 3 i'll take the
e4 pawn
yeah that's okay roop de one I can go
Bishop it six at least maybe something
else but I like we should be six that
definitely I would use it some pressure
oh wow wow wow wow another Knight f3
check out anyway I don't really see how
I can avoid to take from backhand so
here just came to see eight yeah 95 is
no good I think pawn takes bishop at
three EF six looks kind of dangerous but
i'm not sure if it actually works pawn
takes d5 bishop at three EF six bishop
t1 EFS takes on g7 g8 rogue age 7 hmm
yeah maybe white kind of has to gamble
this this kind of things already
otherwise it's just busted anyway so
Bishop at three takes Knight takes
bishop f3 takes on f6 61 takes to 70 g 8
I don't see it I don't see it yeah but
hmm okay I don't see it so if i do this
why am i not better here after Bishop GA
drooped g8 he's got three pawns for the
peace but he hits 3g bonds and yep let's
take it always like to simplify if
possible and this one and this is this
is this is the android
five can also can also take it
check
check I could have got to have 7
immediately there was no particular
bigger DM I should have played Bishop g8
it would have been a little bit easier
to win
no I didn't really have I didn't really
look anymore because i really ask myself
why is he not resigning here the salon
so check and now he has a real reason to
continue this is not not even clear here
if i'm from winning yeah i didn't i
didn't pay any attention anymore it's
just what happens to me and
unfortunately quite often in situations
like that simply didn't look
you
time morning yeah this is this is no
objectively a draw I guess we will
probably manage to to trade trade things
off check check check see one's just a
bond holding check check check white
forfeits on time yeah it was was kind of
embarrassing that I did I simply didn't
pay any attention why do it doesn't even
give up this because it's completely
lost check but ask him I just had to
play um just forgot that I'm should play
Bishop 388 first which I wanted to do
but then I did this and well yeah I mean
this is totally easy no I block this b5
take the pawn and so on and here and I
can still take care right
check and here this is probably
objectively a draw I think I don't know
I think you should be able to to trade
this down to Luca and Bishop again
stroke yeah the shame because it was I
think a pretty decent game even though
here I would and I wondered late if I'm
why I didn't take him check check isn't
this good for black somehow when this
this looks like it's trapped okay where
the computer thinks why it's better here
okay it's got several pawns yeah we can
two points probably yes where pawn
structure is also very bad okay so this
was all right and i played this very
sharp move I don't really know that
works and the engine thinks it doesn't
work it wants to play this now but this
is also a pawn it already dislikes
knight Knight f3 check I know the engine
gets black an advantage anyway yeah me
it didn't work what white was doing when
this definitely doesn't work he has to
play Bishop cheeks here's the engines
recommendation check check this is
actually need if i go here group
everyone and i have no way to prevent
this wow wow so i have to play this
check it here white at least is fighting
and just exchange down this is a coupe
this is a total when 95 is even stronger
Oh
okay but whatever a plate is enough it's
just a piece on time to claim it just
plays anger is that you could say that
that white got back into this okay
thanks for watching